make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I know this is gonna sound
really strange but we're covering
deceased now here's the thing we're
covering be ceased the unkillable right
so this is a three-issue miniseries and
it's gonna be monthly right so the next
one's not gonna come out until March 18
at the time that we're recording this
video but it looks like Tom Taylor and
DC are expanding on the deceased
universe right they're expanding on this
whole story which kind of makes sense
right like it's one of the things that
the people who read Marvel Zombies kind
of got this feeling of okay we think
they're gonna start expanding and giving
us more stuff and that looks like what
they're doing right how far this
expansion is gonna go we don't know
right I mean I think we still have the
follow-up story to Constantine and all
that kind of stuff and then basically
this answers the question of what the
villains were doing but this one
specifically focuses on the Red Hood
right so what this does it initially
picks up with Deathstroke picks up with
Slade Wilson and it's actually one of
the coolest things right because Slade
Wilson has basically been hired for nine
million dollars to kill a whole bunch of
guys who were essentially taken out of
church right I mean these guys you know
committed a violent act against a church
and so Deathstroke's been paid nine
million bucks
to essentially get the revenge the
problem is when he shows up here one of
the guys is jumping out with shattered
legs and it's just like running for his
life but then comes to the realization
this guy was running from something
right because you know as soon as that
happens the door comes crashing open and
there's all these people who come
running out as well and Deathstroke
starts you know going to kill them only
to realize okay there's a bigger issue
at play here 20 ends of realizing into
this this house is basically filled with
zombies now again Deathstroke despite
all the abilities that he has and the
technology he usually has at his
disposal once he goes on a mission his
only concern is that mission right so we
can largely go with the idea that he's
been oblivious to what's going on this
is especially important because this is
day one right the outbreak just happened
the infection just took hold so it's
really one of these things were it's
like he alongside so many other people
are just now being caught up in it but
he doesn't really look at his phone all
the time what he's doing is he's
basically like peering at his missions
and so as a result of that as soon as he
gets in here of course he basically
starts going through and trying to kill
these guys but as we know it's very very
difficult to do that right shooting them
doesn't really work that instead you
kind of have to like decapitate them or
something along those lines but then
ultimately Deathstroke ends up looking
at his phone realize that you know being
like okay like time to basically say
alright let's follow up with this like
we got it we got to get this sorted out
so that payment can be increased
essentially or something like that only
for Deathstroke to be infected with a
virus and so when that happens he starts
to go on a warpath but then suddenly his
healing factor starts to kick in right
and where he had basically made his way
into the city and was essentially taking
everybody out once his healing factor
kicked in did it purge the virus from
his body right so this is the first real
instance that we see that the virus can
be cured something that that cyborg had
basically figured out at the end of the
story or at least at the end of the main
DC story before he was killed by Wonder
Woman and so what this does is that it
switches over to Jason Todd and that was
the big question people had right people
wanted to know what happened to Red Hood
during decease what was he doing play
was he one of the first to fall we just
never found out what was going on with
Red Hood and so by the time we get into
day 2 Red Hood assume presumably we
don't really know what he was doing
during day 1 we can largely assume that
he figured out what was going on and
then came to the bat cave to basically
figure out you know to talk to a Batman
or whoever and see if anybody has any
idea only to come across the bodies of
Dick Grayson and and Damian Wayne and
Batman and essentially find out that
like they're dead and so with that being
the case of course then he's met by the
arrival of ace ace the bat-hound which
we're glad to see he's alive ace the
bat-hound is also kind of a alarm system
to a degree right and it's a really
smart move by Tom Taylor because it ace
can really kind of be used is like an
early warning system of like it infected
right so like if they go into an area
into a they walk up to a building and
because dogs you know since the smell is
so keen that you can pick up on the fact
that there's infected there then it's
kind of an early monitoring system okay
tread carefully or let's sleep right so
you know basically you know using some
wood he ends up carving out some
gravestones and ultimately ends up you
know using the Batmobile to find the
heartbeats of the various members of the
bat family in Gotham City and only finds
two now despite his separation from his
family it's also an important thing to
understand that over the course of DC
Comics it's been well established this
slate for the most part loves his family
it's his idea to keep them safe
especially rows right and so the idea
here at least what we end up really
seeing go down here is of course she
gets a call from Slade and Slade says
like it's time to go we have to leave
and Rose responds by saying no that's
not gonna work because I've seen the
future and every time I open the front
door I end up dying now here's the
important thing to understand about
Rose's precognition it's not
precognition in a traditional sense
meaning she's not actually seeing the
future the way her mind works is it
basically takes
situation as best she understands it and
then it arranges and gives her the most
likely outcome right so literally it's
just mathematical probability is more or
less how her brain functions it's just
really really really accurate most of
the time of course Slade Wilson
basically chimes in and just says no go
on to the rooftop you're not gonna be
stuck you know where she starts to freak
out she thinks she's gonna get stuck on
the rooftop you know the response to st.
is no you're not everything's gonna be
fine I so she gets to the rooftop a lot
or drops down and then slaves met by the
arrival of man-bat and it's kind of cool
to see these characters that we never
saw during the original DC story right
the idea of man-bat coming cruising in
you know and then just like going to
attack slay the helicopter ends up
crashing now of course man bats killed
in the explosion and initially the Oh
Rose comes the conclusion that Slade
himself was infected and then goes to
stab him and then when Slade says wow
that is just kind like okay my bad but
basically yes when we kind of get this
confirmation did that essentially the
healing factor of Slade Wilson is what
keeps the anti-life infection more or
less from taking him over you know it
keeps the virus from turning him and
keeping him into one of them that his
body can quite literally fight it off
right and so what we end up doing is we
end up having an appearance of mirror
master and the reality is that mirror
master is probably the one character in
all of DC comics at least as far as
earth-based characters who would be most
likely to be completely unharmed right
because the guy can basically exist like
he can bounce through mirrors right
that's his whole idea is to see and talk
to people through mirrors to leave the
mirrors if he chooses to and so he's
literally the one guy who could just be
fine he could go inside mirrors and then
always be safe there and whenever he
needed food or water or anything like
that then in turn just jump from one
location to the next right he could
always find a way out but what he says
is there is a collection of villains who
have survived right there's a collection
of villains who were there I can take
you to them you know your your presence
has been requested by Vandal Savage
there's an offer that he's bringing to
the table where these goggles come with
us these goggles will basically prevent
the the anti-life equation from taking
you over but you might want to close
your eyes as we're passing through this
mirror dimension right because when you
wouldn't they walk through that realm
all they see are just mirrors everywhere
that just show like dead bodies right
dead bodies people turning different
things like that just how bad the
infection is and that's what we pick up
with Vandal Savage
and it's kind of interesting right
because the you know as I was reading
this Vandal Savage never really crossed
my mind when I was reading the original
deceased story right I was reading that
and it never
heard to me that vandal savage has been
around for an exceedingly long amount of
time
and the Vandal Savage would well he
wouldn't necessarily have planned for
this
he wouldn't know how to cope with the
situation and that's basically what he
says here right he says one I've been
around this world for a very very long
time this is not my first extinction
event and - the heroes are going to fail
because the heroes don't are they're not
able to do what they need to do they're
not ruthless enough to do what needs to
be done in order to win and we know
that's true because we've seen howdy
ceased plays out instead of focusing
their efforts on eradicating the virus
and eradicating everybody who's infected
instead they focus their efforts on
protecting people and putting people
into a safe location the result was that
they may probably one of the worst
decisions they could have made and they
consolidated all the superheroes down
into one location so that when one of
those heroes became infected then they
knew where everybody else was right so
it was probably one of the worst and
biggest blunders the superheroes
possibly could have made in that
situation in reality they should have
just spread out but maintain contact via
like walkie talkies or something like
that you know some method of
communication there was essentially
old-school but wouldn't actually reveal
where their location was nonetheless we
end up finding this this surviving group
here is composed of some pretty
interesting characters right we've got
Solomon Grundy we've got the creeper who
can heal from pretty much anything
you've got vein you've got Lady Shiva
you've got Deadshot you've got Captain
Cold you got cheetah which only we know
why she's there but you've got a
collection of some pretty interesting
characters here and so what you end up
doing is you jump back over to Jason
Todd right and this is really the meat
and potato this is really what you guys
kind of came to see with regards to this
this deceased event is Jason Todd
picking up in Gotham right it's night
two of the anti-life virus and one thing
to understand is that for the most part
we're not really going to see much of
Slade Wilson for the rest of this story
we're not really gonna see him at all
instead the rest of this really focuses
exclusively on Jason Todd and so what we
end up having is Jason Todd is showing
up to Gotham City Police Department
talking to Jim Gorn or at least arriving
on the scene when all hell's breaking
loose and one of the things that they
intended to do you know Jim Gordon and
Harvey Bullock was to basically fall
back to the cells right because this is
all just kind of popped off and where
Batman hasn't shown up yet the idea was
that Batman will show up eventually
right like Batman will arrive here at
some point along the line but but the
issue is that he hasn't arrived yet
presumably because he's tied up with the
infection just like everybody else but
Batman will be here that's the
philosophy ideology of Harvey Bullock
and Jim Gordon and so it's like fall
to the cells it'll bias time for when
Batman gets here and Batman will save us
now Harvey bullocks infected in the mean
time and then of course you know you end
up having his neck broken by this this
member of the bat family who's there but
the number of the bat family it's not
really talking to anybody right and
there should be a first clue as to who
this person is and so in the middle of
all that you know you end up having like
the wall that smashes down Jim Gordon's
like oh my god it's Batman you saved us
some of the zombies are shot in the head
and then Brett hood comes out and says
no I'm not Batman Batman's not coming
Batman's gone Batman's dead right and
it's one of the most crushing things to
hear when you're Jim Gordon because it's
just like one in the heck right because
initially like his immediate response is
wear red hood says like we have to leave
Gotham we got to get the hell out of
this place this city's fallen there's
nothing to save here the response of Jim
is no we have to save my daughter
Barbara and at that point red hood
chimes in and says no you're Barbara's
gone like Barbara Gordon is gone she's
dead and Jim Gordon's like well then I I
need to know why I need to know for sure
the heartbeats pulled up her her
heartbeat is basically flatlined Red
Hood ends up taking Jim Gordon to
Barbara Gordon we also find out this is
Cassandra Cain who's basically the last
remaining member of the bat family which
seems pretty appropriate given how well
the fighter she is how good she is it
hiding sneaking being in the shadows
things like that she'd be able to keep
herself well hidden from everything else
going on but essentially once they
travel and they locate the body of
Barbara Gordon of course it's all
stringed up we know that from what
Harley Quinn had done when she had faced
off against all of them and basically
with Barbara Gordon's death confirmed
Jason Todd then turns his attention to
the Joker and Jason Todd's pissed off
Joker was killed before Jason could get
to him and so one of the cool things
that you get out of this Jason Todd what
he ends up doing and probably one of the
coolest aspects here one of the coolest
things is in order to get his revenge he
basically takes the body of the Joker in
strapped it to the front of the
Batmobile and it's just like let's go
like the the bat tank and it's just like
let's go like we're getting out of
Gotham City and so what they end up
doing is traveling to blüdhaven on day
three of the anti-life fires and the
realities of blood Haven has fallen and
you get this kind of funny thing right
where Jason Todd's like it's almost kind
of an improvement but but at the end of
the day Jason Todd is ruthless right
Jason Todd will do whatever he feels
needs to be done in order to ensure his
own survival in a situation like this
and he basically looks at Bludhaven and
says the place is fallen right the place
is falling there's really nothing we can
do here now you do end up having you
know all these zombies surrounding one
particular building and the response is
okay there's people in there but Jason
Todd wants to leave Jason Todd's like
let's go the responsive Jim Gordon is
we have to save who's there were the
good guys it's what we do and this is
what Vandal Savage is referring to when
he says that the good guys are
half-measures the good guys aren't
really able to do what needs to be done
in order to save the world so Jason Todd
basically disengages the safety
protocols on the bat tank fires Rockets
takes out a whole bunch of those guys
and then when he shows up there he ends
up realizing it's housing a whole bunch
of orphans ultimately Jason Todd ends up
siding with the orphans and is kind of
okay orphans got to stick together and
so how many of these kids are gonna
survive we don't really know but it
really kind of seems to be going in the
direction of this story the fact that
the first issue didn't really introduce
anybody other than like Jason Todd Jim
Gordon and Cassandra Cain as well as you
know these these orphan kids who were
here as well as Slade Wilson his
daughter and the various villains who
survived it looks like this deceased you
know villains story unkillable is gonna
be confined to this this is really all
it's gonna be so anybody guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here two comments explained make
sure you guys at the sub-12 become part
of the robb for if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop on like and I
will catch you all later peace
okay I want to give a shout out to Kyle
be David Joseph Ben
john h aj matt in Jeff are John H lean
and mean which is an awesome name Jason
see Austin s Austin Ajo am Steven Z
Austin be Adam K and Genesis 9 16
remember guys you could send me messages
and I'll run off whatever your message
is at the end of the video so long as
there's nothing crazy but if you want to
put a message in there send me an email
Rob at Robert Jefferson calm and if
you're one of these people who get
shoutouts
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch it guys
[Music]
[Music]
you